[Musique]
installée car nous allons attaquer la
deuxième partie où sept poids nouveau
rang monsieur olivier rhône et avec les
pièces noires et moi que corneille avec
les pièces blanches
[Musique]
on va passer donc à ce deuxième match la
revanche de cette première partie dans
ce match entre mathieu cornette et aux
libéraux d une première partie
finalement terminer assez vite dans le
calme monsieur ils ont une position
symétrique et on arrêtait la musique
alors que c'est parti avec eux quatre
ces cinq cavaliers froid voilà des six
donc on est dans une sicilienne wallonie
sienne qui me rappelle ce qu'a joué
laurent frayssinet il me semble dans son
premier match puisqu'il avait joué un
plan avec food et trois pouces et 2
voilà donc là il joue le petit coup h3
tout en maintenant je crois que c'est
aussi ce qu'avait joué dans fasciné me
semble
on va voir si c'est un peu le même plan
dans la foulée 3 l'idée c'est de mettre
le fluence ces deux vies de jouer des
quatre plus tard alors ça je leur dis
lui que je connais pas bien je ne sais
pas trop quelle est l'idée est exact
mais bon voilà en tout cas c'est ça ce
jour là jouaient ce tableau me ferait
signer à jouer exactement cette variable
cet après-midi ce que j'étais en train
de dire oui au nom effectivement j'ai
six mois là on veut mettre le fou
angers7 ici regardons donc on donne le
nom des cadets qui ont pour montre en
même temps la case pour ceux qui n'ont
pas l'habitude de les stages réalisés
c'est normal d'ailleurs là que les
joueurs de clubs vraiment c'est un
schéma inconnu qui connaissent les cases
parker ou des 3c 2 voilà avec l'idée
plus tard de choubra et il va jouer des
quatre l'idée de h3c que comment vous
jouez des quatre donc bien contrôler des
quatre on veut pas que ce qu'elle y soit
loué par le fou puis aussi on veut
assurer la case 3 aux foules cases
noires à 101 ans qu'ils soient délogés
aussi par le juif ou 3 et pas se faire
je n'ai presque dire jeunes à partager
quatre ans je jouais fouet trois pour un
jour allait contester le puissant fou g7
alors jouer empois 6 et essayer de les
changer
bonjour doc d2 et ensuite x 6 en fait
tout ça c'est du long terme
oui mais c'est là la pièce puissante des
noirs ce sera le fou g7 donc on est tous
des variantes un peu non mais cette
variante est est à la mode et pas mal
joué intéressante
alors attention du rhône et n'a pas
réussi à gagner avec lui dans tout à
l'heure donc le match reste très
équilibré et donc
maintenant tu connais pas les blancs
donc petit avantage à mathieu cornette
peut-être que les jeunes vont faire la
grande surprise de cette première
journée après romain edouard qui a sorti
island douchy quand une grand favori de
ce grand prix dans le mélo du tour moi
donc pouy petit rock petit rock et des 4
et 4 donc ça y est les blancs essaie
d'imposer de le forcer entre des 4,4
soutenu par le pion ces trois séquences
par off qui adorez cette structure ces
trois des quatre 4 on appelait ça le
centre d kasparov
le centre de costaros et des bras des
cavalcades il l'adoré c'est un champion
on rappelle que centre celica sky est un
jeu casse 4 allée 4 case centrale oui
pas facile voilà donc là on en a deux
qui contrôle les cases d'ailleurs qui
sont devant donc c'est un centre costaud
ouais voilà un jour ou l'autre
ce chat ce centre havas mobilisez vous
lavant de tâches de ce centre c'est
qu'on peut jouer cinq si on veut on peut
jouer des 5
on peut donc créer des problèmes sur le
cavalier sur ce cavalier on peut à tout
moment donc il faut que nos calculs
toutes les possibilités à tout moment ça
peut ça peut exploser donc ici cavaliers
ses 6 il 6 mai ils organisent la
prescience sur le pied en d4 pression
qu'il a pas peur de dessins qui
fermerait le centre où il dira au nez
puisque alors ça c'est sa ferme le
centre qu'est ce qui jouerait là sur des
scènes par exemple ils s'envoient
blindés 5 pourquoi pas oui mais oui ce
qu'on ferait cavalier on irait peut-être
en a 5 voit pas
ou éventuellement rabais 8 on reviendra
mais 8 - moins possible en scène
puisqu'il suffirait de prendre de
l'échangé et le pion ici serait mal
placé puisqu'il boucherait le fou où les
7 et je pense pas qu'on ait joué des
quatre pour jouer des cinq combats
peuvent vous décapent des salles à jouer
des quatre pour soutenir un jour la
poussée aux cinq plus tôt vous cette
poussée là et jouer contre l'europe mais
là je pense qu'il va jouer peut-être un
coup comme un fou et trois tours ou un
possible aussi davantage de foudroyage
ça pose la question en pions c5 puisque
sa menace pions prends tu comprends et
free prend pions
quel match jeu tout à l'heure encore
j'en reviens pas toujours sous le coup a
donc il a joué à comprendre ces sections
processeur ou intéressant puis on
pensait 5 c'est à dire que mais il est
satisfait de tout ça que voilà le
cavalier oui il est satisfait de
de sa structure ses trois b2 qui a noté
que ce taux soit pas au fouquet's est là
cavalier c'est sûr parce que là on g4 il
sera en prise s'il vient h5 il simple
coup g4 et gagne la pierre il a plus de
cases puisque en f4 il ya le fou ici
regardez le fou contrôle donc à manger
trois espions dont il lui reste la case
1,8
donc il reste plus que ce chaos les une
seule case disponible c'est la case de
huit médailles joue par l'iphone 5
non parce qu'après il faudra à protéger
le pion au havre le soutenir pour
soutenir ce pion qui sera après qu'elle
eut été attaquée par le cavalier par le
fou donc il a préféré qu'il a joué faux
et 3 le coup à la normale que les deux
il veut sortir ces pièces à vendre avant
de jouer deux fois la même pièce halo 4
on remarque un match correct qui joue
quelque chose de relativement calme
finalement oui calme il s'est assagi
avec l'âge et en rencontrant des joueurs
qui se laisse pas faire il est obligé de
de s'assagir
cela conduit nerveux à quand il était
plus jeune
comme il avait beaucoup de qualités
tactiques il dépassait les joueurs qui
lui était opposé donc il n'avait pas
peur de compliqué de compliqué mais
contre un joueur plus fort et classe
d'olivier rooney on ne peut pas se
permettre de fermer pour de de mettre
les pièces sur des cases sont
quelquefois eur26 donc ici cavaliers h5
il a dû prendre quelques défaites
retentissant voilà une comédie il veut
il veut installer le cavalier en f4 pour
gagner la paire de four ou pour avoir un
cavalier puissant alors la case f4
souvent attaque la dame elle est oui
elle allait être la dame protégé par la
donne c'est 7 mai la case f4 souvent et
très intéressante lorsque l'adversaire a
joué le coup à trois puisque si on veut
chasser ce cavalier par le pion jeu le
coup j'ai 3 il faut penser à voir aux
pions h qui deviendra prenable sur échec
23 ici donc la structure apte h3g 2
souvent appelle un cavalier à venir un
f4 parce que cavaye âge de lui en
expliquer qu'un voyage 2 donc on va
rappeler ici les colonnes mais c'est du
f g h et les traverses ici un autre 4 6
et 8 comme la bataille navale la
huitième traverse la 4e traverse
ici la colonne h voilà donc on repère
les cases facilement la case e5 est ici
voilà tac cette case là et donc la case
h2 ici moyenne h2 évite donc là le coup
cavaliers h 2 oui qui menacera cavaliers
g4s que peut-être sur cavaliers de 4 il
veut jouer d'un ex 3 wii et surtout
lequel le coup cavaliers achetez donc
prépare la venue du cavalier un g4 pour
aller jouer pauwels this pour jouer le
fou ici où le cavalier puisqu'il peut
pas échanger le fou avec d'amener de
fouet 3 et la batterie habituel il
menace mais ce cadre oui mais 4 c'est
peut-être pas urgent parce que il ya
beaucoup le prix de pions h3 déjà
affaibli un peu leur aucun des huit
jours des nuits pour l'intérêt d'être 4
aussi c'est que la tour après contrôle
lacazette 4 est donc appliquée aux
livres car on peut menacer d'être g4
ouais non ça va pas
il ya des pénétrations après il faut pas
trop affaiblie oui moi je pense plutôt
pour le coup pour le coup cavaliers pour
le coup cavaliers ou non les blancs trop
mais il faut aussi penser à la colonne d
un jour si le noir commence à voir une
tour sur la colonne mais il faudra
peut-être s'y opposer aussi un jour il y
en a une
oui mais je parle pour les blancs s'y
opposer oui pour remettre une tour ici
par exemple être une tour ici ces
dépositions calme pour l'instant
première de cette première partie cette
deuxième aussi donc à 4 joué par matthew
cornette pour la l'idée de quatre îles
scilly gilles abandonné la colonne le
pion à 7 donc je peux être je peux me
servir du fait qu' al assad mais six
pour ouvrir la colonne à mon équipe et
ce n est pas possible puisque le pion
serait reprise 5 faible ici ouais
mais surtout ce il va avoir une colonne
lui aussi pour sa tour en compensation
de la colonne des lui lors la colonne a
donc assez vite aux yeux rogner jouer le
couffo 6 bon contrôle ici diagonale un
vide mais bon surtout il a libéré
l'action de sa tour des huit voies qui
tape maintenant tout le long de la
colonne sur le directement sur le cahier
des deux même s'il n'y a pas de danger
ce qui est très bien protégé mais on se
fout bouger un peu sur un six sur six
tours d un sa joie si vite
oui ça y est il vient de mettre une tour
imposés 14 minutes 14 minutes
alors attention puisque si l'un des deux
joueurs gagnent cette partie le match
est plié terminer quel que soit le même
que l'ail et s'installe sur la fameuse
casey fratrie là il avait le temps
il est donc là la question et douleur
soit on les prend avec le fou et ça
donne un père de fou il ya de fous et la
vienne n'a plus qu'un et soit il joue le
coup peut-être plus probable je sais pas
d'âme f3 mais dans ce cas là il y aurait
qu à lloret qui ont rallié les trois ces
éléments b2 et cavalli pénible c'est le
problème n'est peut-être pas vu ça c'est
le problème du pian ces avancées où je
vous donne ses deux pions c3 une fois
avance évidemment la case d3 est devenu
faible alors d'amener fin pour contrôler
la classe des 3 il faut bouger cette
dame dans ce cas là si on prend pas
parce que sinon le cavaly attaque la
dame
donc voilà souci pour mathieu cornette
quoi faire cela met fin elle serait pas
s'ils vont assez passif mais bon la f3
la mef 3 il ya cavaliers detroit qualité
3 c'est juste alors c'est pas simplement
fou présentement cavalli prendre
cavaliers dans la paire de faux mais
dans la paire de fou pions
parce que c'est embêtant de données se
fout quand même deux cases noires en
plus qu'à l'air pas mal parce que ce fou
ici pour l'instant il tape sur ses
propres pions n'est pas très actif
alors il vous le coup passif mais je
t'aime f1 et parce qu'il faudra qu'ils
jouent g3 pour chasser le cavalier c'est
un peu facile parce que je voyais paris
control détroit il veut absolument
contrôler à cake et cavaliers detroit il
veut pas donner la paire de faux
gratuitement mais bon il va s'il va se
résoudre à jouer à jouer j'ai trois pour
chasser ce cavalier peut pas il peut pas
jouer 3 puisqu'elles font aussi ce
qu'ils attaquent h 3 et wii
en même temps que lecavalier donc il
peut pas il peut pas la dame ici
contrôle h 30 mais ça suffit pas il faut
une pièce de plus juteux pas il jouera
g3 quand il aura joué cavalier g4 oui
messi joue cavalier g4 il va se faire
chasser renault par h5 et le cahier sera
obligé de revenir anges 2 heures en
ayant perdu un temps donc il est un peu
il est un peu dominé la mathieu corne
est semble-t-il ça se voit aussi au fait
qu' il est sur ses quatre premières
rangées à ses pions les pièces épisode
ainsi sont les pions à 4 et des pions eu
4 alors que les noirs ont une pièce dans
le camp ennemi
oui c'est le carrier peut-être donc car
quand même légère avantage noir le noir
à bien organiser ces pièces à des
meilleurs l'hégire avantage meilleure
pièce mineurs attention attention
attention
non c'est pas le moment de perdre la
partie pour mathieu cornette puisque ça
serait l'élimination instantané
peut-être qu'il a joué à 4 pour 1 pour
assurer la cale ses quatre à cinq
cavaliers assomme cavaliers des deux car
il ya cinq fois on n'est pas là de toute
façon il ya encore beaucoup de coups oui
avant la fin et puis de toute façon il
n'y a pas davantage le net oui donc là
il léger petit avantage car il ya cinq à
dix mais la pression maximum elle est
absolument qu'il joue comme il ya 5-6
dans le blanc allait jouer cavalier
à ces cas-là il comprend très bien
toutes les cases là avec le fou avec
lecavalier il empêche les blancs de
bouger kalyev trois mènes jouer mathieu
cornette 1,6 voilà est-ce que c'est pas
un petit coup ça de parties rapides
sismiques ou nantes on sait pas trop à
quoi ça sert c'est surtout beaucoup
d'attentes mais il a son intérêt ces
colis des îles à son intérêt il prive d
un casier sa menace et il m'arrivait
cinq mandats c'est d'aller en g5 qui
voit tout en ironie donc très souvent
agen est souvent un petit coup les pions
qui permet de contrôler les caisses des
pièces du coup de côté là demain tu
cornette un coup prophylactique là
encore peut-être il veut éviter des
sacrifices plus tard faut prendre
comprendre car il prend avec échec
on ne sait pas ça peut si on veut
libérer la dame par exemple et là il va
peut-être il ya des soucis quand même là
pour se libérer de l'emprise des noirs
mais pour l'instant rien de concret pour
les noirs une pression sur les cases un
bon cavalier f4 bien protégé pour la
dame voilà il augmente la pression
libéraux nez tranquillement autour des 7
et il veut jouer tour des huit doubles
et les colonnes les tours pardon sur la
colonne et faire pression sur cette
colonne des voilà la fameuse
colonnes que l'ont envahi avec les tours
colonnes d'hercule
alors on double sur la colonne et on
menace on menace d'avoir des tours
puissante et les blancs sont un peu
resserré la à moi je serai positionnait
les blancs soit un peu resserré et la
dame noire et mieux meilleur que dame
blanche les oui elle tient bien le
cavalière catherine camille f4 un grand
prix très quand même très équilibré
depuis le début oui où la dame j 1 et
tenant à l'idée c'est fouad habash de
blizzard se fout l'idée c'est de jouer
des matchs de chz prince h2 pour eux
s'ils savent allier damage de nom pour
changer les pièces très très original le
plan de match cornette la saddam était
pas terrible sur syfy va essayer de
l'améliorer en moyenne d'oubli des
renault aussi ici que non seulement plus
vu d'un match où met on pas aussi les
cavalières alliée fin aussi cavalière
femmes pour d'étranges évidemment un bon
moment et oui au bon moment des faits
font les formes plus des trois attaques
donc attaque l'invasion de la case des
points attaque le plan des donc sa force
presque fou prendre voilà difficile de
voir sinon qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce
que là si on joue par exemple b2 b3 et
bien tout simplement fou princes et rois
princes et trois ateliers ce serait
grave ça serait très grave non là il
faut malheureusement joué faut prendre
cavalier-cheval ans il a joué quoi ton
bien tombe bien il veut retarder le plus
possible le fait de se séparer de la
paire de faux j'aime pas trop mais pas
du tout la position de mathieu corne est
là mais ça reste passif
ça reste passif extrêmement passif là la
pression augmente là il n'est pas à son
aise dans cette position trois énormes
ici c'est pas une position qui lui
convient oh là là mais pourquoi il a
joué sept variantes et olivier relais
toujours très sérieux avec
si léché bien vient organiser ces sites
ou grand mère c'est un grand maître
c'est pas pour rien l'an dernier il
avait gagné le nacional b en france
jouera le à cette année il va faire des
petits dés des joueurs qui vont jouer le
titre de champion de france cette année
avec laurent frayssinet avec joie
l'outil mais olivier grenet est un des
grands espoirs des échecs français
il ya une quinzaine d'années bien sûr
oui c'est un grand joueur il a consacré
beaucoup de son temps à l'enseignement
des échecs et il continue à le faire en
région parisienne l'a fait un petit
passage à toulouse pendant deux ou trois
ans je suis lancé dans les échecs il est
revenu à paris et joue pour le club de
de clichy sans doute poussé sans
inquiéter le club de ses origines alors
il nous annonçait qu'il allait nous
faire la joie de de participer vous
prend dimanche aux championnats
d'aquitaine de parties rapides au qui
voit là et s'est inscrit oui il est il
un bien il aime bien le club de la rue
buhan il le connaissait il avait déjà
fait les coupe de france contre contre
nous il ya quelques années et donc
cavalli il voulait revenir avec plaisir
dans ce lieu carly un attaque la tour
[Musique]
tacle est alors la tour al orouba les
atouts rebelle va reculer
elle va partir obligeant venu en relève
à retire l'opinion 17 alors que vont
faire les blancs il faudrait s'organiser
pour pour échanger mellal kallio s'est
fatigué s'est ainsi voulu jouer quatre
mois c'est ça l'idée c'était ça ou sdf 4
s4
alors pourquoi f4 ben hilli le lit le
fouillent la dame
oui et j'en ai fait jouer car il
récupère la case f3 pour trouver 4 pour
le cavalier ne peut être joué des quatre
meilleurs de voir une fois qu'il aura
joué cavalier f3 il pourra jouer beckham
four b3 nous dirons nous et oui c'est
laisse pas un terme à remiser ses perdu
6 perdus ça y est un fauve et 3 il va y
avoir parce que sur ses seins et bien
voilà il va y aller deux pièces aux
mains deux pièces pour la pour la tour
en prendre deux pièces et six cavaliers
prend fou et bien il ya toujours aussi
fini thorpe retour d'environ légalement
il va y avoir de la pièce du sein
on est ici complètement laissée dominer
dans cette partie il a oublié ils pas
rentrés dans le match
il a oublié pas rentrer dedans c'est
d'avoir été forcée et il va prendre des
pièces pour la toux n'y a pas réussi à
prendre
voilà tout reprendre à la wii 2 pièces
pour la toux un gros avantage pour
olivier rhône et donc damas trois gros
avantage pour olivier rhône et dans le 3
voilà la kbc comme si horrible olam est
si horrible cavaliers c4 oui ça tire la
dame l'idée totalement en dessous la
mairie 3 mais cécilia pas réussi à
rentrer dans le match et c'est pas
facile de jouer contre olivier parce
qu'il a il a un très joli à regarder va
se passer g5 se passe-t-il songé 5
olivier un très joli style champions
prend g5 évidemment la dame prendre et
comment les blancs peuvent protéger le
faire qu'ils peuvent pas aussi horribles
sont complètement ficelé il le fait même
pas il fait tours 4 ça y est la tacc
pions et gsm cavalaire très très fort le
pion à eux alors le foot m le four b3
immobilise complètement les tours on
peut pas venir en d1 et japonais ainsi
qu'un horrible là mathieu corps n'était
pas du tout a pas du tout réussi rentrée
n'a pas du tout réussi à rentrer dans le
match
donc il veut jouer cavalier f3 mais il
va perdre le pion 1,4 et le pion f4 et
emprises aussi non mais là la c c'est
horrible bing pour des amateurs corne
est là dans ce match il n'a pas réussi
du tout du tout à décoller je passe qui
lui est arrivé voyez malheureusement il
n'a pas joué à son meilleur niveau
bon de pièces mineurs et puis c'est
difficile il faudra un miracle
maintenant pour mathieu cornette pour
revenir dans cette partie et essayer de
sauver ce match mais la vie rené semble
bien parti maintenant pour se qualifier
en demi finale depuis l'alliance est
celle au 1 c'est très très dur tout la
paire de faux mais il ya la peur de vous
en plus c'est maintenant le pire à 4 et
tombe comme un fruit mûr
ouais c'est vraiment horrible ce qui se
passe à mathieu kornati continue mais
est-ce qu'on partisans qu'il
continuerait cette partie continue brute
sans doute ils essaieraient de la jouer
quand même un peu ces désespérés mais
c'est super il s'est très
c'est m6 je pense une fois ci le pion
aux six qui tombe peut-être un simple
coucou me 6 c'est un peu comme le 6 je
pense que si le plus insistant bon monde
prend le pied en mai deux et ça
m'étonnerait que la nation attention
attention vallier g5 qui aurait faut
prendre cavaliers il n'ya plus loin
parce que ferait la dame hannachi c'est
la passe et le souci à ignorer que le
cavalier qui ont dominé le fouet s'ils
dominent le cas mais moi je pense qu'on
peut jouer faut aussi s'il manque une
pièce assez mature cornette la praxis ne
servent alors qu'albert le pion mais ne
s'est laissée ramassé sur ses quatrièmes
6-4 angers parce qu'ils étaient
resserrés il avait une position resserré
je ne suis pas un début très très aussi
très très agressive et quand vient des
trois essais de c'est très bizarre qu'il
ait vu qu'ils ne deviennent pas alors
qu'on a vu jouer qu'on fasse alors en
faux site est d'ailleurs un début très
agressif
oui très notamment dans cette année donc
et il l'a battu et attention aux
positions resserrées encore une fois il
y avait je crois que c'était harrach qui
lisait les positions soins quand même la
menace internet c'est tout point cet
accord cette tâche disaient les
positions resserrées contiennent en
elles le germe de la défaite est souvent
une policiers ont resserré tôt ou tard
ça les petits problèmes arrivent ça
craque et c'est pas le style de position
qui convenait à mathieu donc là le lire
on y réfléchit mais c'est sûrement pour
au mieux
oui oui là olivier rhône et mieux s'en
servent ils sont à égalité resserre donc
là il va sans doute jouer aussi sur les
mots je pense que c'est trop moi je
jouerai faux m6 et puis je prendrai le
pion b2 l'influencé serait pas beau à
voir après le fion le piora pourrait
aller presque adam tout seul à 5 à 4 à 3
oui le souhait de saint vallier dans
prend 1,6
ouais cavalli prend b2 oui c'est ça
on peut pas mener de renforts
effectivement c'est possible je vous
avais léger scène qui menacerait faut
prendre on peut prendre le cavalier avec
le font bien sûr et puis les dames après
gagner tout seul bien sûr mais il veut
sans doute pas laisser une chance une
seule chance de contre attaque a battu
cornette olivier rhône et donc y
réfléchit bien dans ce match et briser
ce match bizarre impression qu'il a qui
n'a pas vraiment eu lieu en fait il a
joué faux v3c same way to b 3 cahiers de
roubaix trois ponts b3 ils laissent
faire divisés alors le coup qu'est ce
qui se passe là se retrouvent prend le
set
quelle est l'idée d'olivier rhône et
surtout prend 2,7
ils veulent faire mathieu n'a pas le
choix il faut qu'ils essayent de mes
yeux il veut trouver l'idée c'est
bizarre comme il faut que nous mettrons
un fond m 3 qu'est-ce qui se passe et
puis on recettes étant prise alors
surprend le 7 une idée ça pour eux de
jouer d'amd 8
la tour est clouée sur la dame wind est
menacée fouet pour changer les dames
pourrez choisir la partie va vite mais
on gagnerait surtout la tour je crois
non parce que la dame est protégé par le
cavalier donc on peut enlever notre sort
lentement mais voilà il prend voilà qui
fait tâche d huile ça c'est l'idée est
maintenant dame
attention la menace 1,8 à voile assailli
les changer d'âme voilà c'est ça l'idée
c'était ça l'idée c'est horrible il veut
rentrer dans une finale c'est horrible
d'échangé d'un puisque là maintenant la
dame ne peut pas s'échapper après ce
delà du roi qui était derrière il y
avait voilà
plus âgés accord maintenant échange de
dames olivier rooney échanges il a une
pièce de plus mais c'est bizarre parce
qu'il donne deux pions quand même hein
il va donner l'option là ça fait
beaucoup quand même moi je trouve voyez
mais les deux de fou sévillan s'est
offert une énorme par rapport à une tour
de fonds de fonds bien plus fort qu'une
tour des fous sommes plus fort qu'une
théo largement largement dans largement
plus fort donc il va il va essayer de
sauver cette partie tu confondrais
calais c'est de trouver at il eu le sort
et essorés vraiment me rendre à guillet
s'est trouvé un homme s'est tué lors
leurs cavaliers cinq ans il va prendre
du cavalier oui il va prendre du carami
menace que la loire du mal à apprendre
ici et apprennent du cavalier pour
rester avec nous il faut qu'entre la fin
du fou sinon je pense qu'il veut rester
avec les deux chocs entre la tour il
faut qu'il reste avec les deux faux
pendant la tournée on valoir il prend
oui voilà
oui et puis là il va jouer tout
simplement roi est fluide
on y va il va laisser tomber des plus
belles dames faut qu'il fasse attention
quand même nom il va jouer il va garder
son fiancé puis les deux fous il a gardé
le pied danser les deux fous là il est
bon on peut que je me sens pour le pire
ou 5 le plan voilà il va prendre le pire
est certain qu il va sans doute perdre
et puis en v6 oui mais il va rester avec
jouer ces quatre oui va jouer ces 4 et
ensuite fouet f4 voila voila fou et 4
tout de suite ça la preuve qu'à tout de
suite comprend et il va jouer poussé les
rendements de 2 ans et 3 et s'est
complètement gagnant les deux fous sera
énorme
on peut vous tous réussissent pour
défendre mais comme andy lau des
flandres on n'a pas pu je trouve qu'ici
tu peux pas défendre
voilà le tour si c'est parce que le
fouetter un f4 il faut pas le pouvais
pas la rd6 f6 dans la saison et la c6
c'est clairement fini la plus réussie
s'il aurait pu venir en f2 mais de façon
c'est fini il peut rien faire oui donc
l'appareil en deux tours est roi il
suffit voilà non mais c'est horrible y
ait eu en plus de ce côté en plus
la hisser deux fous des trente pas tout
de suite fossé de à cause des torts f2
qui gagne est l'un des deux fours à oui
mais il faut jouer d'abord fou à 3 puis
fous ces deux foulées trois places et
serrault diouf ou à troyes puis ensuite
tb il va les pas pressés olivier rhône
et dans le matériel va jouer fossé de
ces deux maintenant oui à tout de suite
non tout d'abord le f4 va le faire
maintenant je pense qu'il a joué très
précis ivey seyed et dans cest toujours
mieux c'est difficile à la sq on assiste
à une mise à mort quasiment tous
collégiens on est en plus une minute
d'avancé
oui il a aussi une majorité mobile sur
les droits et l'âge orité de ce côté là
et il a trois contre deux et le problème
c'est que les noirs protège très bien
leurs pions c4 sans problème mais par
contre là il va jouer à j'arrive à jouer
à je prends g4 et puis roi f6 et ensuite
voilà variation de plus ou moins bien
donc pas à l'essayer sont trop forts les
deux foules aux minarets ce qu'une seule
pièce pour protéger le pion l'autre
pièce pour attaquer il va tenter de
l'embêter jusqu'au bout mais on les vire
au nez on lui fait pas on ne la lui fait
pas à pas mais un petit échec voilà bien
sûr il a tout vu
il a bougé le fou voilà et le fou à
venir essayer d'en à trois blessures
pour venir profitions b2 mais ne l'ont
pas le pian médoc voilà donc tourné
voilà empêcher et maintenant tour c'est
un foot cm puis parlant poussé m puis il
faut les deux et puis regardez comme le
foot est comme si puissante sans passe
droit d'avancer en plus ne peut pas
avancer le pion ici empêcher les cases
blanches
le full classement ils peuvent vendre à
tout moment le hilal en est là là là
c'est une petite question technique fait
d'ici c'est un gars n'a pas réussi à
rentrer dans le match du tout il n'y a
pas eu de d'ailleurs la première partie
a été nul à sévir dans ce type de
position il ya encore un dernier espoir
c'est la fameuse tour folle c'est à dire
s'est débrouillé pour pat tu es le roi
blanc on n'est pas un échec mais on peut
pas bouger il ya la sacrifie la tour
voilà et après ans
roman c'est un sacré souvenir on y va
tomber donc c'est sûr que non il va y
penser mais c'est le dernier espoir des
blancs passes tes pattes et le roi pour
pour jouer la tour folle avec émotion qu
on ait raté des coups plus fort alors on
appelle ça le stratagème de la tour
folle c'est une tour qui menace le roi
échec échec l'échec et qui ne peut pas
être prises à cause du pat donc c'est le
dernier et ultime espoir de cette
position il va peut-être on sais pas
peut-être encore mais ça serait vraiment
voilà là c'est horrible c'est dingue
comme c'est pas jouable c'est pas
jouable
un roi des huns c'est horrible mafoud et
3 voilà ça y est maintenant c'est le
pion session c'est le pied en rêve qui
est avancée ima jouer regardez en plus
comme les foules à contrôler toutes les
cases ici donc ce pion on peut paraît
testions il va pousser pousser pousser
s'est séparé table le pied on va faire
ce qu'on appelle le voyage accompagné
fait pour wild 2 pour maintenant il va
jouer f3 elle va être accompagné par les
foules sur la jusqu'à sa promo siro
c'est horrible horrible c'est horrible
non mes filles a rien à faire f4 voilà
c'est horrible par des combis peut rien
faire les deux fous sont beaucoup trop
fort en lettres iso si c'est pas lancer
le fameux pattes il aura vu olivier
rhône et voilà la sauvegarde sauvetage
incroyable
olivier s'il vous prend et bien c'est
pas ces s'est pas dit les pattes c'est
l'art c'est la tour folle donc essayons
d'y et la rogne et il est si kid
ah non mais alors là à essayer de
glisser çà rôle alors quelle erreur de
nom maintenant il faut encore travailler
avec les noirs pour aller gagner le giro
c'est quoi c'est pas clair maintenant
incroyable sauvetage alors que travis de
matu corner talent là et on est super
cette partie ou alors s'il fait nul dans
cette partie voyez là il a oublié a
regretté vraiment
oubliée la pole la pâte oublier la tour
folle oh là là quelle partie vraiment
difficile qu'est ce que c'est difficile
donc maintenant il va essayer de faire
le tour avec le roi pour aller capter le
pion avec le roi ne pourra pas s'il va
essayer d'aller capter mon ami pourra
pas il pourra pas parce qu'il va se
prendre des échecs respondents des
échecs
voilà le roi est coupée c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour ça va ça m pour mathieu il
est impressionnant milla il a sauvé
l'incroyable olivier rhône est tombé
dans le piège du pat de la fameuse tour
folle que tu racontais ou sur l'iphone
second bébé est en fait s'ils écoutent
mathieu il est tombé dans le piège
mathieu avec moi a pris quelques ruses
pendant quelques années donc ils les
utilisent encore d'une ruse a cédé russe
de nice et de siu qu il défend sa il a
sauvé la sauver son bifteck l'on n'a pas
en sa chance et l'environnement peut se
maintenant il a un mauvais roi prendre
la tête à deux mains oui alors il essaie
de trouver un plan qu'est ce qui va
faire fourrer 6 très bizarre il veut
essayer de passer sans roi de l'autre
côté cette voie là alors si les blancs
prenaient le pion vous pour se dire les
noirs peuvent plus faire damer de fou
suffisent pour mater de faux suffisent
pour mater il faudrait pas non plus que
voilà il ya des difficultés dans
l'attenté le gain réalisé il ya des
difficultés techniques laisser
complètement endormir il ay la jouer
mécaniquement
techniquement il fallait que tout le
royaume pour le mettre en sécurité et
qu'il accompagne le pian passé avec les
deux avec les deux faux voilà ce qu'il
devait faire pas pouvoir gagner et il
n'a pas fait il est tombé dans ce petit
une ruse attention on peut encore perdre
1 on sait pas je voulais dire aux néo
peut perdre maintenant c'est comme si
parfois il faut pas abuser car un comme
c'est parti
il va essayer de travailler autrement
comme quoi ce que disaient les kills une
fois les deux filles gagnent mais pas
les trois c'est quoi la foi et faut pas
être fou soi même un jour à n'importe
quoi ça c'est pas bon c'est pas pour
faire la troisième
le troisième fut de l'échiquier c'est le
problème
ouais donc comme quoi on n'a jamais
gagné une partie en l'abandonnant il
aurait pu abandonner c'était perdu
techniquement et puis le jeune demande
que faute incroyable c'est une partie
vraiment alors mais ça va être nul ça va
être nul parce que là non mais on va
dépasser les largement les la répétition
depuis les cinquante coups c'est
incroyable incroyable
les 5 arrive à rousset lors c'est un
match très très bizarre quand auquel on
assiste
première partie finement il faut quand
même toujours faire attention très vite
mais la dr une grosse gaffe aux
avantages pour olivier rhône et qui
décidément derrière bien il va essayer
de progresser avec l'erreur et comment
il peut prendre et ce avec ces fous mais
attention la règle des 50 coups et je
crois qu'elle est valable même en partie
rapide
50 coup joué sans je sais pas champion
pousser ça en prison vous et que je
connais pas trop les il va peut-être
l'endormir aussi au lit rhône et l'ain
peut-être essayer de menacer je ne sais
quoi
elle voulait prendre mais voilà alors je
suis passée du roi wave 3 peut pas être
joué là oui il faudrait qu'il arrive à 4
il faudrait qu'il arrive attaqué deux
fois le pian ces trois c'est-à-dire
amené le roi en d2 amené le roi en d2
et à voir le fousseret diagonale qu'est
ce qu'ils essaient de faire
mais il veut amener le roi des deux
bornes et le roy on est doué mais c'est
pas évident parce que la tour empêche de
toute promenade
alors est-ce que les 50 concerts je ne
sais pas si les 50 km marche en partie
rapide je crois pas parce que l'on note
pas les coups alors voilà il ne peut pas
progresser c'est vrai c'est donc ça va
ça va se terminer en partie nulle garde
la corne est incroyable croyais alors on
va encore assister à des blitz mais
décidément aujourd'hui tous les matches
à part celui de laurent frayssinet se
seront déterminés en vie et là olivier
on et rate le coche et battu cornette va
devoir se réveiller enfin sur les blitz
là il continue a coupé l'accès à houla
ça y est cette fois le roi va pouvoir
accéder à la case des mais après si
viande et de vous qu'est-ce qui se passe
donc tous là où la houlala
ah ça y est il veut jouer tour campion
si je comprends bien ils annulent
attention à tout reprend pions là parce
qu'il y aurait un chèque à voilà il peut
pas ghatak et deux fois le voile à
prendre la tour et moi c'est nul voilà
sans lacets ville ces deux défenseurs
croyable
belle défense et de mathieu incroyable
qui a su profiter de sa chance alors
qu'il avait une pression incroyable
positions perdantes incroyable partie à
rebondissements où moi que korn est là
mathieu va de nouveau avoir les blancs a
réussi à arracher le nul
il avait les
les blancs ça va de nouveau avoir les
blancs erronée olivier rooney qui a
laissé vraiment pas là il a laissé
passer sa chance et qu'elle colle à la
10e' le berceau naturel et l'énergie oil
energy pour nom mais je crois pas
qu'elle volonté pour ne pas abandonner
ce lire je continue ou le but on va
échanger on va revenir on va changer par
rapport à par rapport au match donc je
pense qu'on va revenir à voile à corne
et premier vrai c'est ça vérifiez
connaître rené voit dans la foulée il
n'y a pas de pause à ya pas de pause bon
j'espère que je vais porter chance à
mathieu chaque fois que je le soutiens
comme ça il n'y a pas de pause il gagne
ses matchs et se qualifie jours après le
transfert premier titre de champion de
france minimes moi j'étais derrière la
barrière pour son dernier match
alors ce match vous de le soutenir nous
réveille et il lâché il a rien lâché et
au final nous oui non
nous c'est plus nous surprend nous
surprend où je demande un match très
bizarre d'aller très très très bizarre
ce match belle défense la
psychologiquement pour rené d'avoir raté
ce gars-là c'est oui c'est tellement
dominé ça va pas être facile
oui mais si c'était moi je suis ainsi
que c'est pas facile de revenir
ouais mais là en deux parties rapides il
est et comme tactiquement il a il a
l'oeil vif
on va laisser partie 5 à 3 des 6 et 3
même s'il ya un coup la valeur est la
même avec la variante où les oliviers va
pas en raison de changements h 3 à 3 oui
cavaliers prend 1,4 vers la pièce avec
elle ce qu'on appelle la variante du
balayeur damas quatre et d'apprendre à
bien des matelas échec au roi et d'un
point quatre dom prend cavaliers voilà
ça s'est pas fait donc c'est la partie
tout à l'heure c'est la même non non pas
la même image où tout un c'est pas tout
à fait part ici
non c'est pas pareil c'est pas du tout
oui un peu plus et il a compris la fille
se réveille un peu il va la jouer un peu
plus nerveuse que tout a l'air de
laisser 6 tc troyes pour ces huit là où
il venait d'être énervé contre lui-même
oui bah oui bien sûr d'avoir atteint
cette partie très bizarre ce match très
bizarre et ouais c'est pas trop quoi
penser
c'est un heureux comme en football
dominer n'est pas gagner exactement
il s'en sort bien pour l'instant mathieu
cornette le premier maître international
bordelais qui pour l'instant on n a pas
réussi à rentrer vraiment dans le match
il a sauvé in extremis cette deuxième
partie et pour la troisième fois de la
journée nous avons droit à des bills
seul laurent frayssinet est passée sans
les blitz il a gagné 2 0 oui sans passer
par les beats alberto david est passé
par les blitz passer par les blitz et
maya noir abattu en douchy au blitz mort
subite et maintenant c'est au tour de
mathieu cornette et olivier rené de se
départager en bistrot quatre minutes aux
blancs 4 minutes au noir pour l'instant
dix minutes
utilisez donc ça peut aller très vite
évidemment ça va aller très vite et donc
de mai nous aurons donc pour l'instant
les demi finales entre edward et david à
17 heures et à 15 heures ce sera la
demi-finale entre freyssinet et le
vainqueur de ce match entre mathieu
cornette et olivier rhône et quel match
très bizarre
vraiment peut-être le plus bizarre qu'on
en ai vu à ce grand prix de bordeaux de
huawei c'est un match et aux normandes
avoir besoin de rythme et puis sauvé
cette partie sauvé cette partie
complètement
perdu façon totalement inattendue avec
ce fameux ses revenus annonce 10 coups
avant que encore le seule façon de s'en
sortir si la tour folle ouais et au
final il ya une tour folle ouais ouais
quand même extraordinaire
en tout cas ça prouve que lui on est
tentant pas sinon il se serait une fille
je serais méfié
il s'est mit s'est lui-même laissé
endormir d'ailleurs olivier ont déjà une
pression ont dû trouver ça un peu trop
facile et s'est un peu relâché c'est le
risque
oui oui on est pensé que tout gagné
quand on est joueur d'échecs combien de
partis on dit qu'on aurait dit mais
malheureusement les grands généraux ne
sont pas ceux qui auraient dû gagner ce
sont ceux qui ont gagné c'est ce qu'ils
ont gagné
alors ça y est aux cinq scinder prend
voix l'aï lu mais le avril après sur le
fameux graal mais une vraie pression là
maintenant confirmer conquis qui aident
à l'attaquant va changer la soirée donc
grosse faiblesse sur 15 mois pour chez
olivier rooney puisqu'avec ce pion et 5
contres la case e m6 il suffit d'avoir
un gros cavaliers en raid 6 oui ce soit
y arriverait par quasiment maths alors
qu'avec h5 probablement se prend fou oui
il faut pas qu'on élimine le fouet mais
non on voit bien qu'il ya des problèmes
sur caisses noires à l'opinion
s'inquiète une épine dans c'est pas
terrible dans la position des noirs
toujours un jour cette case f4 l'afrique
à travers l'idée surtout prend fou
évidemment on reprend de la vallée et
hop
et puis on menace aussi il soit même des
six 6 ans menace aussi faut prendre et 7
et cavaliers aux quatre ans menace de
vous prendre en 17 jours là gros
avantage blanche cavaliers ou 4 puis ça
s'est fait très vite
mais vous savez déjà ce cliché 4 pour
chasser le cavalier à l'effort de m6
ailleurs la dame donc le match bizarre
alors quelques données à la dame voilà
le problème
dames 2 oui c'est le sait le plus
logique oui mesdames les deux cavaliers
à quatre avec tempo et blanc sont
beaucoup mieux la bible en sont beaucoup
mieux
les blancs sont mieux oui il ya quand
même un gros trou ici le l'oeuf okada
s'est changée feu sous faulx bessette et
après calais ou 4 est possible avec
avantage là dessus parce qu'il va avoir
un gros échec qui tient cavaliers en
herbe six cavaliers
c'est une belle bête quand même une
grosse bête mais difficile à maîtriser
il a des problèmes olivier rhône et
l'ain il a de gros problèmes de défense
sur cases noires affaiblissent il ya
encore la dame qui qui va défendre les
casseroles à la dame que oui bon ça va
être ça va être quand même
il a aussi les deux tours sur les deux
colonnes ouverte
je préfère les blancs quand même si
j'avais à choisir une position a joué un
jeu choisir il blanc oui oui le cavalier
à 5 et pas très heureux sans réfléchir
les fameux cavaliers au bord les deux
cavaliers noirs sans bords de
l'échiquier cavagnoud bon oui bon
souvent c'est plus quand les cavaliers
jeudi - sont moins bons que consentent
puisqu'une contrôler que tout simplement
que quatre cases au lieu des 8 pour lui
des huit possibles au centre d'où
l'intérêt d'être au centre
alors ça y est cavalier f4 et cavaliers
décès c'est pour cela il veut quand il
veut garder le fou pour contrôler il
veut surtout reprendre éventuellement du
pion des noms mais il veut changer ce
cavalier a compris qu'il veut pas que
lorient attention mena 5
il faut dans ma fuite est obligatoire à
saillé d'un match 90 cavaliers j'ai cinq
ans à bord non mais quel gsm c'est pas
très grave on joue à six ou 5 1 s'est
passé pas très grave oui mais qui
voyageait 5 après fou promesses être
visera la case de 4 ha oui c'est vrai et
reviendra sur m6 tu as raison donc là il
va jouer tout reprend tout reprendre
pour alléger on prend on prend c'est
vrai ici récupère aussi voilà il dit
prendre mais sur fond de la smat avaient
ils menacent maths et ils menacent
d'aller re sur m6 il va prendre
alors ça c'est les coûts typiques de
mathieu il reprend pas bêtement et
automatiquement
il a la lucidité de voir le coup plus
fort la chine va essayer installations
il y est il y installations et à la case
et six gros davantage blanc je connais
tu peux prendre l'avantagé par dia
cavaliers
on les dit roland maintenant la balle et
il va sans doute lui tricoter une petite
histoire avec dame j'ai trois cavaliers
h c'est bien un plan très simple f4 pour
consolider au 5
oui il ya aussi d'abord il ya aussi tous
rejoint faire tourner la tour touché 3
et puis se servir du pierrache pour le
prix hommage va servir le pion à celle
plus récents servir au tour à tour trois
ils amènent ces trois pièces sur sur le
rôle du fonds
c'est très fort dans l'oreillette elle
que y'a un p'tit coup qui était
intéressant je suis étonné que mathieu
n'est pas vu que vous montrez vite une
combinaison la table la dame était en
fuite on pouvait jouer tour 4 avec lions
n'a pas te regarde
il y avait l'idée
très belle et très mal être il y avait
l'idée dame price 6-1 en estrie où
l'accord il prouve c'est qu'il l'a pas
vu décidément cavaliers h5 échec puis on
prend dame prend olala ça va se terminer
là le roi noir il faut le royaume et
projetait de forcer si on joue à l'on
voit la f6 oui même s'il pourrait faire
échec donc en proa h5 là le roi noir
états en dessous france là c'est
difficile à tour g8 forcé pour t3 le a
le temps il va perdre autant et on
essaie de 17 secondes oui ça y est ça y
est mathieu gagnes pas tu corner 20e
cornell se qualifier puisqu'il ya six
mois gagne le public
il ya une première glisse oui eh bien il
revient de très loin wheeler et on le
comprend 3 6 l'apa problème je collais
mathieu il valait mieux les coups et il
va tenir malgré tout aller danser c'est
fini le plus de temps peu importe la
position il va tomber d'un an
il n'y aura pas de nul endroit il va
tomber ils veulent faire tomber c'est
fini et olivier rené quatre secondes
c'est fini c'est fini maintenant ils
essaient ils essayent mais non il peut
pas je connais la fin du film il peut
pas à essayer par la tour enfin c'est
fini voilà ont terminé de toi arrange
les pièces bon c'est bien ce que je sais
bien ce que j'espérais en partie rapide
mathieu avec ça son énergie et sa
jeunesse à la vente à jour mais il
fallait qu'ils tiennent dans les parties
blanc dans les parties de 20 minutes ce
qui la fait difficilement dans la
deuxième
komatsu ont du mal à démarrer et
maintenant au top donc là on a une
partie avantage puisqu'ils y manque la
torah 8 winock une tournée faudrait
aircal et la tour la tour à 8
dans le cadrage à mathieu après avoir
frisé la correctionnelle
voilà vous avez l'avantagé rétabli alors
natation maintenant on doit l'emporter
avec les blancs pour pousser mathieu
cornette au but poursuivi était
décidément on a des matches à rallonge
aujourd'hui tous les matchs quasiment
donc difficile pour olivier il doit
gagner cette partie là nul suffit à
mathieu c'est la nature avec un trait
particulier aujourd'hui dans celui-là ce
dernier match on est là bien sûr bien
sûr il avait levé son plus gros travail
doit être d'évacuer cette partie de ne
plus penser de se reconcentrer dans le
match c'est ce qui est le plus difficile
dans ces circonstances là c'est parti
la fondue le sirop mise à à 5 minutes
chacun donc on va voir le gars me dam de
tout à l'heure sans doute un sauf que
mathieu n'a pas joué au cices cette fois
ci a haussé d'un homme en différé oui
dix ans ils ont la position tout à
l'heure avec un ordre le coût différent
[Musique]
ça je pourrais pas jouer moi je penserai
trop c'est quoi c'est une tâche là c'est
ça c'est une sans doute je vous dis pas
ça ici les deux pions ici qui menacent
de s'échanger à tout moment des deux
côtés
la petit rock avec les donc le roi se
met à l'abri ici on a sorti le fouet en
b2
voilà donc ça va vite allez vite voir
beaucoup de coups s'enchaîner très
rapidement voilà c est difficile à
suivre
j'aimerais pas être à la place beaulieu
moi j'y penserai encore on web et oui je
pourrais jamais vraiment compris février
surtout dans ces circonstances là où il
faudrait qu'ils lisent mais après
mathieu a joué aussi
il fallait aussi il a joué de bien
défendre avec la tour même quand on a
gagné et on le sait tous à fond juste
fonction il fallait jouer avec précision
les c'est la tour offrant un papa se
faire enfermer la tour est coincé pour
pour regarder ses pieds il a gardé cette
idée en tête de tours folle après la
russie à la bien sûr mais je me rappelle
la première fois que je vais montrer ce
genre de truc quand il était gamin
jouant mais voilà c'est arrivé le jour
est arrivé il pensait pas que ça serai à
bordeaux
ota féminin un bus après ces superbes
comme comme situation l'écran géant les
joueurs sur la scène plus l'émotion mais
moi si on les met des couleurs
oui là je sais pas si les cauchemars il
ya eu de belles empoignades
alors de belles parties s'est
brillamment de douchy qui est passé très
près ouais c'est toujours un beau combat
une partie d'échecs est en train d'être
joueur qui qui ne lâche pas tout de
suite la position on voit que c'est
tendu on voit bien que le que le stress
est perceptible oui oui mais la tension
est très forte
les échecs sont devenus un sport et
c'est pas pour rien il faut insister les
spectacles comme ça pour pour s'en
rendre compte
pour vraiment le vivre effectivement
d'un v8
alors donc enfin l'attention se relâche
sur 10 un peu la case h2 sur les
positions de pierre on vous prend qui
étaient envahis les images en fait aux
lyonnais éliminés que les six parce que
ce genre de coup c'est un coup à jouer
kable g4 pour menacer un dame prend h de
maths en éliminant préalablement le
khalife 3 et ils préfèrent éliminer tout
de suite mais il veut surtout faire des
pions panzer oui aussi bien sûr mais
gagner un mathieu corner mais voilà ça y
est tout de suite dit on et prend
l'avantagé dans ce deuxième liszt est
décidément alors si olivier rhône et
l'emporté on aurait droit pour la
deuxième fois la journée au un blitz
mort subite
décidément du mal à dormir un bon mais
pour l'instant alors attention attention
pour l'instant ce n'est qu'un pion il ya
encore un milieu de jeu avec une paire
de faux vous disais cavaliers ou quatre
attaques la dame protège la tour et
surtout on prend l'idée c'était de jouer
fois cet échec et tours pendables mais
ça marche pas mais le pian et la traîne
le feu en pêche qui n'a pas droit de
jouer fou saute le pion pour faire échec
on n'a pas le droit de sauter des pions
c'est important de le rappeler mais
merci quand même donc la tour 8
vis-à-vis tour dames avec la menace de
jouer sans doute des 4 c'est cette fois
c'est peut-être lié au nez qui va jouer
le coup d'un défunt qui avait été jouée
par mathieu dans la partie et dans les
parties concernant la partie
resserrez tête ou les dames et fun parce
que le coût des quatre élèves quand même
un pénible
oui il faut absolument qu'ils louvre le
centre contré de casser on le pion de
alors quand je vois mais lui ça ne pèse
pas encore sur la position tant que tant
que les fous sont là que le centre est
ouvert un jour dans mes fins aurait été
à c'est pas mal aussi fou b1
alors l'idée sans doute sur des 4 6 2
août cavalli eu quatre ans lire yes et
surtout dans le détroit
fauchon et damages 7,3 m c'est
simplement donné 3 passes et sur les cas
des booms échec est presque maths quand
on est presque le match et qui a pas
brillé
et puis pression sur ya quand même de
gros soucis pour le roi pression sur le
pire des menaces par exemple cavaliers
cavaliers ces quatre ans menacerait si
on joue d'amd 3 me lasserai hannache
cette année on associe cavaliers c4 il
se passe quoi camembert ou simplement la
puissance de la tour voilà donc j'ai ça
c'est pour contrer le faut bien
il veut absolument installer une pièce
en d4 pour que le pion rester fixé sur
la case des cinq je pense que c'est ce
que veut le blanc pour les blancs oui
mettre en cave à nice mais il se prépare
à faire enrôler des cavaliers pour pour
d4 pas tout de suite non mais il va
l'organiser donc plus pour pour olivier
il va sortir la dame et quick halal ya
deux ans il a joué ça pour jouer
cavalier deux écueils et les cas en plus
c'est une majorité éloignés mais son
gros avantage blanc pas décisif mais
quand même gros avantage blanc mais bon
on a vu qu olivier a dit emballé à
transformer donc locke le pion des 5es
et là la paire de fou
la moindre valeur cette paire de
foulards oui voilà donc qui l'envoie là
ça y est il est laissé de là ils
essaient de fixer sur cette voie là des
6 et le carnet savoir que le foot se
libère voilà tu souffres bc l'idée donc
il reprend du pillon il va sacrément il
va essayer le plus possible de le
maintenir se baigner on s'en prend dé 4
je sais que ce coût à oui biensur
superbe sur dame pour dames train
touristique
et oui la fameuse ça marche pas contre
plaisanterie cavaye f-16 parce qu'on
fait d'un programme pour prendre et tout
repenser c'est une petite combine est et
cela et récupère le pion à cela mathieu
ne les ratez jamais cela à j-4 ce type
de combinés à l'envi très fort parce que
h4 menace maintenant dans prend oui mais
ils le font ne sera plus la mlh cinq
semaines le fournil sera plus immersif
mais on prend attention le roi ça c'est
très clair que ce type de combinaison
mathieu en a tellement fait pendant les
séances d'entraînement qui ne les ratent
pas des six
attention quand même il veut jouer dam
des cinq peut-être pour menaces et mat
bon j'ai deux voies la tour il veut il
veut contrôler la case ou 4 notre mieux
donc là on est on est dans l'égalité de
matériel mais déséquilibres importants
paire de faux dans un centre ouvert
avantage noir bien sûr avantage noir
c'est fini l'a pas pu laisser sa pièce
sur des quatre ni le bélier d4 d5 donc
damas adam b4 il est prêt à changer les
dames est rentré dans une finale à lévis
les gens l'unpr de tours vie dont il
veut pas changer des dames au lit du
rhône y va jouer des mecs 400 ouvriers
olivier non là est chargé les dames
sinon c'est ces parties perdues ou
mieux nul f4 donc attention parce que
tour c'est 7 serait pas jouable si ça
allait je sais pas pour ces sept fous ou
5 d'un même cet été subit maintenant
cesser cette formation il faut des
formes mazamet vii
oui touré fuite il faut défendre pour la
fuite semble jouable
oui tourelles fuite ou food et 5 suites
et préfère thorel fuite c'est plus
agressif ou ses quatre échecs je sais
pas si c'est bien ça fout c'est à
tricher ah oui touriste est d'accord en
tout la sensée prendre d'apprendre
menace date limite maintenant il va
défendre
oui mais il perdra le plomb pions g6
iloafo bessette qui traînent on a mis à
la dame a bien sûr l'adapt loué la tour
à tour et fluide cloud la tour f cell
donc le fugu bessette pour l'instant
d'un référendum ces serbes c7 la paire
de foot est toujours vive et 21
septembre
le fougueux cet état d'âme à 8,6 plan
c'est assez cool penser au coût de la
mairie village avec mathieu hausse il ya
dans le ca lanka 3 forcé trois pions de
préemption prends ça y est attention fou
le pion v6 laprie prise prise prise
fougue 4 ou le la cavalier
cavalière 5 qu'est ce qui se passe non
je prends ça y est cheikh
ça y est le cavalier et chloé lecavalier
cloud et maintenant on va venir
l'attaqué attention la smat
qu'est-ce qui se passe obliger à la
salle hyper les pères la pièce ouh là là
là ça s'est joué en quelques coups en
quelques coups et olivier rhône et
semble devoir gagner cette partie encore
et on devrait assister à un blitz mots
reçus comme il reste il reste quatorze
secondes contre 23,8 14 ouhlala c'est
fini c'est matt seimat échec et mat
lalalalalalalalala gramoli aller atx
quel match décidément aujourd'hui en
bolivie erroné parce que le match ait
âge là il fait bon corner
et il a bien servi échec et mat il l'a
bien dans le relais et ont été floués
l'eau moi je pense c'est que mathieu
allé gagner 2-1 par les battues allait
gagner ça comme olivier aurait dû gagner
l'autre donc on va dire une partie
partout une partie perdue père cornette
qui l'a sauvé et une partie perdue par
par olivier rooney qui l'a sauvé dix ans
une position compromise
incroyable on n'arrive même pas comment
tu es tellement sale vite
oui c'est là il ya eu un échec et mat
c'est le premier match qu'on voit
aujourd'hui la donne avant il a oublié
la pièce dommage mais là il reste
quelques sous gommage qu'il n'ait pas pu
se regrouper forcer les charges des
dames et tenir la position
dommage quel match donc là faut tirer au
sort de nouveau
pour le beats mort subite puisque la
[Musique]
rivière sonné car sacré blitzer aussi
parce qu'il a réussi à trouver les
ressources active
on va écouter quelle maman je suis
épuisée mois et puis c'est la wii c'est
cinq minutes avec les blancs pour 20
minutes avec les quatrièmes commentaires
de match c'est monsieur rené qui a
importé le temps c'est lui qui va
décider de la couleur avec laquelle il
va jouer
c'est l'ironie qui choisit monsieur rené
les noirs croyant être avec les blancs à
noter qu'il fait un tonneau table
complet là pour récupérer d'un geste
voilà il prend les noirs il a quatre
minutes
alors attention pas c'est que mathieu
cornet talent et blanc mais il doit
gagner alors à noter que j'ai appris
parce que je n'avais pas suivi tout à
fait tout à l'heure mais j'ai peur que
15 minutes soit insuffisant pour g j'ai
appris que tout à l'heure c'est romain
edouard qu'a choisi des blancs ah oui
oui il a gagné face à hicham donc chaud
c'est parti non non non stop dans
l'ennedi pas pris la hall alors ils sont
partis avant qu'on soit prêt donc c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave on va y aller
voilà on y est c'est pas grave on y est
dans cornette blanc soit 7 du rock
je pense que ça va être très dur pour
rené le temps moi je pronostique guerre
autant pour mathieu c'est possible c'est
vrai que c'est pas évident je voulais ce
but là savoir ce qu'il faut c'est vrai
que 5 4 il ya les anciens non moins de
parties rapides comme ça faisait des
blitz
5 et on avait noté que les noirs
l'emporter tout quasiment tout le temps
st gall j'ai décidé de surfer grand prix
de bordeaux de passer à 5 1 les quatre
c'est dur pour celui qui a quatre
minutes
oui mais bon c'est le genre toi forces
égales à six ailes ou forcée si c'était
toujours les mots requis ou force
voisine tu sais à force voisine et 2008
c'est ça pèse la menace de faire annuler
forte hausse il faut pas oublier ça la
menace de faire nul tu sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de morceaux de bois sur
l'échiquier avant de cavale ça soit nul
c'est vrai c'est vrai oui alors là
attention
moi ce que je conseille à pas du tout à
un radieux cornette c'est de jouer une
position plutôt fermé et qui d'urnes
je n'aime pas du tout ce cavalier ici
qui joue contre son style donc une
position ferme et qui dure il a choisi
quoi de jouer une espagnole
c'est ça c'est une ouais ça je ne
saurais pas dire ce que c'est comme
début c'est allé très vite
je ne sais pas j'ai pas vu les premiers
coups donc il faut absolument qu'il
fasse réfléchir ces voix là il va te
poser une salière
il faut qu'il fasse réfléchir olivier
qui comme détroit il veut échanger mes
dents refus non non qui gardent les
pièces 1 mais foutrement bien sûr vous
pouvez même en comprend il faut qu'ils
gardent les pièces il faut qu'il le
fasse réfléchir il faut qu'ils
grignotent autant sept minutes elle pèse
attention elle est beaucoup de pièces là
contre le roi noir
oui ça mathieu il aime bien scindé qu'il
a plusieurs pièces sur l'euro qui
trouvaient toujours des on va pouvoir
jouer par exemple cavaliers puis l'autre
cavalier va venir en h5 pour s'échanger
face à super savent aller vite là il
peut y avoir un match très rapide avec
la turquie coup y songer 3 voulu dire au
nez ça y est laisse le pion b parce que
ça va être terrible dès qu'il a des
pièces sur le rock ou le lire on est
très très mal il est 13 06
attention gros avantage à 28 corne est
apparemment le canal c'est qui est très
très fort en liaison en plus donc avec
j'ai pas si la mine bon cavalier rémy
l'autre j'ai trois dollars mais ces
annonces n'ont ni la tour et la tour
d'où l'idée de tours 6
l'idée c'est simple c'est de jouer pour
retrouver trois voies la dame prend b2
f1 wheel a tout arrêté à temps clair
maintenant il a pris des pions on les
vire au nez mais le but est pas là le
but voilà ils jouent pour mater 21
stations faut qu'ils gagnent en battant
sur la menace elle est simple un ses
tours j'ai 3 puis cavaliers prendre les
7es qu'à l'étranger cet abandon
donc il faut commencer à songer à
défendre à la barre voilà donc là
maintenant surtout j'ai trois ans
prendrait le pian le cavalier de 5 sans
doute et ensuite sur cavani prendre
cavaliers tour g6 et sur qui on prend on
n'a pas peur d'envoyer de renommée mais
une minute 46 donc il faut il à leur
salaire d'obtenir la défense la demeure
et il va essayer de défendre ses seins à
l'air de tenir plus ou moins la défense
olivier rhône et trois minutes 10 aulas
l'homme une 46 pour la chine 46 46
attention à ses chevaux ses chevaux 20
il ya pas de cavalier plus vite pour lui
dire au nez olala g6 non non ce qui
s'est passé il a touché le pion ouais
c'est ça donc dalaï lama hésiter olala
c'est horrible oui il est aller lui
chercher leur one way sayed un allié
très malin ou du rhône et ça va être dur
là j'ai pas mon tour j'ai six enfants et
je pense qu'il va jouer damache 4 à la
nappe a plutôt réussi ses impressions la
mach 4
bon alors pour la regarder pion aux 5
permet depuis le sol ouais je sais pas
damages 4 me plaît bien non ils peur
départ on n'y a pas de prise
elle y est allée il a joué un peu vite
et apparemment il a touché le pion il
est revenue mais comme il s'est rendu
compte qu'il avait touché et il doit le
jouer
ouais mais on n'est pas du bit le psy de
café où on se permet de 1,2 de reprendre
maintenant c'est pas là c'est quand même
le match et ses pages officielles s'est
pas laissé de il a pris mais bon il a
pris c'est sûr qu'il a pris les pions de
le côté mais une minute 39 de 19 ans est
vrai qu'une minute cherche et cherche à
y chercher une combinaison la minute ça
compte
il cherche une petite combinaison si
elle pouvait exister ce serait pas mal
alors est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose non
c'est pareil à un touriste trois menaces
d'employés oui il ya aussi h4h hiddink
qui existent pour bien sûr pour pénétrer
pour pénétrer il ya 11 et 8 il ya 17
iliad à mach 4 1 il peut très bien
attention s'il trouve rien et qui perd
trop de temps et il est se fondre son
avance au temps l'un va sonner à mason
avance des sandales son avance descend
ça devient
et dis que ça y est la jouabilité ajouté
alors je me fais la pièce superbe à
offrir ici fall a rajouté la pièce de
crise c'est trop vulgaire jouer trop
trop de bien jouer le coup à fond 4
parce que le roi trouvera un abri à
nager de m6 a pas mal pour une journée
de la défense en cas de prise évidemment
on échange ici et c'est matt quasiment
maintenant parce que la dame protège
encore voile attention voilà bientôt
trois doivent 3 il veut forcer
bien sûr il veut forcer le passage il
veut forcer pour attaquer fc at il
attaqué pts 7
le salon s'ils changent la tour m6 le
plonger ci sera prenable après aussi un
pesquera le clouage sur la colonne f
donc la wii masse ces pièces valent à
prix bien sûr pour qui on prend 1,4 bien
sûr un e st à toujours à il n'a pas vu
ce jour le petit coup aurait pas dû voir
ça
le petit coûts intermédiaires qui n'a
pas dû voir un qui est pénible
est ce que ce coût est vraiment pénible
c'est vrai ce petit qu'oublier ou voilà
tout le pied en libre d'en jouer olivier
ce 0,53 à la sai est là pour olivier
faut jouer faut jouer il faut jouer ça y
est le 28e seconde attention les tours
presque quatre wild cards l'axé mais bon
ça y est elle est là il va sacrifier sa
carrière il ya de forte baisse mais
c'est bien mathieu on est souvent pas
hésité way et donc ça va être ma tribu
matis vaille à brumath voilà ça y est
c'est matt ça y est c'est mal ça y est
ça y est la citer un bravo mathieu
mathieu cornette a donc remporté ce
match grâce à sa victoire avec les
blancs dans pays de mort subite c'est
pas neuf à nous
belle interview on peut encore les
applaudit en coulisses et les encore
vraiment un très grand match très bon
match voilà toute partie qui est parti
un peu un peu doucement un peu un peu
mou sur la première partie
peut-être olivier donc pas facile
deuxième partie peut-être raté quelque
chose
la fameuse pour folle difficile
d'échapper à sa papauté on le fair-play
d'olivier rhône et on m'a tout ça a été
chaud mais alors gros gros gros retour
en glisse on a vu que tu avais quand
même pas mal d'expérience aussi en blitz
et notamment sur cette dernière partie
comme une belle attaque une très belle
attaque après dans l'église avait dit
deux choses le retour de 8
j'avais des chances de gains ce que je
fais beaucoup mis autant de bonnes
conditions il y aurait tellement seconde
demain mais bon après on est là dans ces
attaques et enfin dans le match
les affaires ici jusqu'à présent un
crayon
[Musique]
belle victoire à l'arraché mais une
belle victoire de mathieu cornette on
peut l'applaudir encore voilà donc qui
jouera demain sa demi finale face à
leurs offres et sid et je vous remercie
d'avoir assisté jusqu'à très tard
les matches sont durs et est vraiment
tard aujourd'hui avec tous ces bisman
suite voilà merci merci et à demain pour
les demi-finales demain après midi pour
les demi finales de ce grand prix de
bordeaux version
[Musique]